there's a sexuality in the series that
you guys are very playful and you think
it's an important part of the series big
yeah it's big no you you uh uh this kind
of a uh
show you you got two you got two big
things you want to happen one of two
things in every scene uh someone's
either going to
get or or or or someone's about to
get and it and and if you can do both of
those if you can have both of those
things oh my God it's a great scene
you're saying that the whole whole
philosophy of the show is that one of
those two things is going to happen
that's what I'm looking for that's what
I'm looking for you you think that's a
formula for success in any show uh it
should be it could be yeah it would help
like I remember when I was a kid I I I
love that show 30s something remember
that I grew up watching that
show not enough people getting in that
show that was the only downside okay or
yeah yeah so if you can have a scene
where like if like often times I if
there's like a scene where a guy is
going to kill a prostitute M and then
that prostitute in order to try to get
out of getting killed makes a p that's a
great scene right cuz you got you got
two things going you got both things
going on there right right that's what
you want to watch
right that's what we go for and then we
try to make it tasteful
yeah I think your description of the
formula says all uh what about it's
pretty much the same thing on down naby
yeah yeah same deal same
thing he he we use a lot of that formula
here too yeah hey we we got ourselves a
peab
body and that's what we were doing and
they give it to
us they didn't say that when they gave
it to us that that's what made the show
great but that's what makes the show
great you know what I'm excited about
Sam Elliott is on show this season I
think we have a photo of there he is he
is one the all-time great western
characters uh and and and performers
what what what's it like having Sam
Elliott on the show well it's it's uh
it's really wild because I've been uh I
was ripping him off for years and now
now I'm in a scene uh he's s sitting
right next to me and you've been ripping
him off for your whole career so I'm I'm
I'm doing him uhhuh in front of him
uhhuh only I sound like a 12 12y old
girl but I'm
trying I'm trying to do him can I hear
what that sounds what's your Sam Elliot
sound like well it's funny cuz I I used
to do it you know I'd be with other
actors and other scenes it was you know
when I would kind of go like you know uh
you really need to reconsider your
thoughts there and then but now the guy
across from me is saying oh you really
think I need to reconsider my
thoughts and then I realized H God
you're uh we're kind of doing the same
thing yeah and I took this from you I
love it it's like dueling Sam Elliot
only his sounds his sounds awesome yeah
he's really good he's got that crazy
mustache he's got the greatest mustache
doesn't have the mustache on a show
though oh not on big topic of
conversation oh went without the stash
went without the stash yeah I'm not
watching that all right
uh no stash no deal I tell you what yeah
if you grew a stash I bet
I'm going take that back I'm going to
take that back yeah if you could grow
St wait a minute I had a beard yeah he
had a beard I had a beard for a while a
depression beard I had a depression
beard and it was a fairly good
depression beard when you say beard
we're talking about facial hair yeah oh
for God's
sake all of Fant I just want
Clarity I just want to make sure we have
yes my wife knows the deal I've met your
wife she's well compensated she's taken
care of in other
ways it's a financial Arrangement you
see oh yeah no I've seen the
house I will I I could never get a a
mustache like Sam Elliot that's that's
nine people's mustaches that have all
had sex yeah